er wolle was mich aufgeregt hat ist ein
kurs des auto jacken des outdoor jacken
herstellers north face bei instagram da
wird behauptet dass das wandern als
freizeitaktivität weißen vorbehalten sei
wandern sei menschen andere auf fragen
nämlich angeblich nicht so zugänglich es
ist da da muss ich sagen das ist das
neueste kapitel im rock wahnsinn ich bin
ganz sicher nicht rassistisch wenn ich
wandern gehen die wahrheit ist in
deutschland kann selbstverständlich
jeder wandern gehen einfach raus in die
natur ganz unabhängig von der hautfarbe
alles andere wäre ja auch vollkommen
absurd muss man ja sagen ich frage mich
aber auch in kommt es das unternehmen so
eine spalterischen unsinn verbreiten
dass sie aufspringen auf diese bewegung
north face glaubt offenbar sie könnten
mehr outdoor-jacken verkaufen wenn sie
das mitmachen die firma lässt sich
neuerdings beraten muss man wissen für
den hintergrund von einer aktivistin und
politologin namens emilia mag sie ist
eine prominente vertreterin der
sogenannte
kritische rassentheorie die mehr die
anhänger dieser theorie verbreiten es
gebe eine grundsätzliche reichende
hautfarben sozusagen und daran seien
weiße immer oben und deshalb rassistisch
und gerate immer unten so ist es genau
und diese ausgerechnet bei linken
beliebte theorie ist gerade dabei
rassistisches denken in deutschland
wieder salonfähig zu machen in den
universitäten teilweise sogar in den
schulen im politischen bildungsbereich
macht das gerade ganz massiv karriere
eine theorie also die im grunde eine
progressiv gewandelte apartheids lehre
ist das ist nicht antirassistisch was da
verbreitet wird sondern das ist
rassistisch und ich sehe das mit sehr
sehr großer sorge wie das jetzt raum
greift in unserer gesellschaft wir
müssen uns sehen ergibt sich ja was darf
ich du sagen ja von mir lena schule was
waren wir jetzt damit kaufen dagegen
nicht mehr also wendet hier trafen wenn
ich jetzt
würde ein kauf über denken ich will
jetzt niemanden aufrufen nichts zu
kaufen also man so muss jeder selber
wissen aber ich fühle mich also von
dieser art der werbung nicht
angesprochen
eine blüte der identitätspolitik doch
was ist wirklich sagen so wie die alte
weiße mann warum gibt's zum beispiel das
ist ja auch so eine blöde für mich alte
weiß männer das wurde stigmatisiert weil
die haben ja noch nie gelitten und die
sollen jetzt selbst war führen wie sie
sich das wie es sich anfühlt
diskriminiert zu werden das ist ja
selber zu hören genau aber ich sage
immer lieber alte weise männer ich finde
das ja völlig hamburg zum beispiel alte
weiße männer und das jetzt auch ich
finde und das ist aber das problem die
firmen trauen sich nicht mehr nicht zu
ändern will firmen trauen sich nicht
mehr so jemand nicht einzustellen weil
die wogen stimmen sind viel lauter und
jeder der was dagegen sagt hat
eigentlich angst das ist wie so
politisch schreckgespenst jeder der was
dagegen sagt hat das gefühl abgehängt zu
werden das ist ja aus wobei der alte
weiße männer warum sagt das niveau
bewegen oder vor allem auf vermisst sie
sagen dass damit der mann schon
zurückschreckt bei keinem mann will
abgehängt werden keine frau auch das ist
man gibt sich schon so jung und wie das
da ist und das ist halt ganz großes
problem unserer zeit glaube ich dass
unternehmer auch nicht mehr sagen ich
bin's gegenstand bei mir wirklich nett
sein sondern jeder macht es mit weil die
linken stimmen so laut sind und ich
glaube deswegen finde ich gutes system
heute mitgebracht hat glaubt ihr nicht
auch dass wir da auf seinen riesigen pr
com jetzt reingefallen sind in dem wir
darüber diskutieren wenn wir uns wenn
wir sagen würden kaufen jacken nicht
mehr als der schuss nach hinten
losgegangen ich glaube das hat dann mit
der ihr eigenen kunden beleidigt haben
jetzt an das stimmt mein gott jetzt dass
wir nicht mehr wandern gehen und ich
meine welche hobbys bleiben denn
demnächst noch über du darfst nicht mehr
zu mathe olympiaden gehen weil das haben
sich ja auch weiße denker ausgedacht
schach spielen darf es auch nicht mehr
weil weiß da immer beginnen
neben den befreundeten nur ziehen aus
köln mit dann geht so wandern gehen ja
ok matte so ja auch es ist ruhig sein
mathematiker die
propagieren da gibt es eine richtige
lösung und so das ist jetzt so kommt
dann die
polizei
wir sind ja wieder wir sind ja
wir haben wir dafür berlin wandern gehen
sogar mit schaefer und allerlei man muss
aber
wir kommen wieder zurück auf berlin
berlin macht uns das ja auch vor und
auch die berliner politik macht es vor
mit dem landes
antidiskriminierungsgesetz bestimmt
schon mal gehört heißt die polizei
kontrolliert jemanden der fühlt sich
bedrängt beleidigt
verkohlt vielleicht von der von der
polizei
bringt das zur anzeige und der polizist
ab das problem dass er in einer
beweislastumkehr
denjenigen nicht kontrolliert wegen
seiner hautfarbe alleine und das zeigt
uns wie
gesellschaftlich dieses problem
mittlerweile geworden ist vom
gesetzgeber geduldet in berlin wir haben
damals wir haben damals mit empörung
reagiert und haben auch unseren
bundesinnenminister horst seehofer
geraten keine bundespolizei mal nach
berlin zur unterstützung zu schicken
weil wir können das unsere kollegen
michael nicht gegenüber verantworten
habe ich an so eine gefahr zu begeben da
wurde dann ja auch von den senator
geisel auch noch einmal schriftlich
erklärt dass das nur für berliner also
eher beamte gilt und nicht für
bundespolizeibeamte aber das ist ein
mann soll gelegen weil in einer in einem
zug quer durchs land fahren also sagen
wir mal von berlin nach stuttgart und
immer ordentlich zum fenster raus gucken
da sieht man nämlich wenn man da
vorbeifährt an den häusern an den
gardinen an den autos an den gärten wo
normale menschen leben und wie sie leben
und was die denken und wie die um ihre
existenz kämpfen und was die wirklich
beschäftigt und dann vergisst man sofort
in prenzlauer berg in berlin wo das
solche schaumkronen ständig neu gebacken
werden ja wo man über so was diskutiert
aber es ist halt nur hier deshalb berlin
ist in der öffentlichen verwaltung
völlig im eimer
aber es ist nicht überall so oder wenn
man so anders hinguckt es ist nicht so
gottlob und sonst wäre nämlich
deutschland im eimer und das ist glaube
ich noch nicht also wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass aus regionen aus stetten aus
bewegungen von menschen die ein anderes
leben leben die entwicklung hier
zurückschlägt auf solche merkwürdigen
städte wie berlin und die in gang
gesetzt werden wir dürfen die auch nicht
aus kommen lassen in berlin mit dem was
sie hier anrichten man muss ständig
drüber reden ich würde gerne einmal noch
auf diesen post zurückkommen weil ich
das so verrückt finde wandern als weiße
männerdomäne einfach mal so zu
bezeichnen das einfach mal so zu
behaupten ich bin mal eine sehr lange
strecke gewandert den jakobsweg bis zum
grab des apostels in santiago de
compostela ich habe dort fast also kaum
männer getroffen ehrlich sagt man da nur
frauen unterwegs so viel mehr zu diesem
thema und ich würde jetzt auch nicht
sagen dass da nur weiß unterwegs also
wandern ist ja nun wirklich für jeden
zugänglich ich muss zugeben es gibt
andere outdoor-aktivitäten zb skifahren
ist sehr teuer das ist tatsächlich nicht
jedem zugänglich aber auch in diesem
post wird ja auch diese die gegen auch
davon aus die natur gehört jedem
schreiben die so
gar nicht wie man auf der ganzen welt
von ölfeldern bis zu zehn pisten alles
gehört irgendjemand und mit jedem stück
land wird irgendwo geld verdient dass
das auch so eine naive vorstellung die
einfach nicht den tatsachen entsprechen
ist kann ja jeder rausgehen im wald und
wandern gehen das ist genau wie du sagt
dass man beim golfclub muss mitglied
werden da hast du vielleicht bestimmte
hürden das kostet ja auch viel siegeln
ist auch teuer braucht und segelboot und
sowas aber wandern kann nun wirklich
jeder ohne jede
zugangsbeschränkungen
aber auch die sind ja nicht so und da
sind wirklich überwiegend frauen gewesen
jacobs alexa senden suchen daher
überraschend wenn ich den männer sind ja
wie ihr wisst ja sind ja wehleidig wenn
dir eine blase amt ist hören sie gleich
aufgaben geben zum nächsten bahnhof
gefahren hause während frauen sind
eisern von ihr laufen beide habe
kerkeling war wandern und hat er darüber
sein bestseller damals hat ihn jemand
beobachtet dabei
unterschiedliche
übernachtungsmöglichkeiten du kannst
auch im hotel du kannst ja auch du musst
auch das ganze gepäck nicht die ganze
zeit mitschleppen ehrlich gesagt diesen
service hatte ich auch dass ich nicht
alles immer mitgenommen habe sondern du
kannst das seit bis zur nächsten
herberge wird also das schlimmste die
hinterher getragen das ist jetzt nicht
so dass das eine selbstkasteiung ist
oder so aber ist privilegiert und das
mögen die wahrscheinlich auch nicht von
meuffels ja aber was kostet denn so
einen ort fest ja ich hab gar nicht wird
wahrscheinlich gehört zu sagen haben wir
20 euro würde ich mal liest du mit
sicherheit nicht 20 euro
[Musik]